how's it going bros my name is Pete
today we're checking out what would you
do when it really comes to it this is
the show where they put people in random
scenarios they staged this usually it's
harassment of some sort and they see how
people around would react
I stole this from Cody Co subscribed to
him I'm sorry but this is right up my
alley I gotta watch this this is girl
gamer harassed by team that's the title
of this what would you do
continues hey why are you playing this
game I know it's like so much worse
though why do you have bigger tits than
me that's how you'd respond come on
girls come on like you would know the
difference smile like you would know the
difference yeah bet you never maximized
cookie mum what is that supposed to mean
it means that girls suck at video games
here give me that
why don't you just go get your nails
done or something you're at a video game
where you see a gamer being harassed
simply because of her gender see this is
what I've been talking a month gamers
are the most impressed group I mean I
didn't say it but we all know it's true
I like how they froze framed this by the
way very cool effect how did they pull
that on or do you step in and tell the
boys game over
what would you do thank you what would
you do yet
that's it gamer girls that will you say
next time oh I'm not a gamer girl well
game over oh I'm not a gamer girl well I
know the difference between the blue and
the red truck is slender game over game
over
gotta girl gamers this should be called
girl lasers
trust girl lamerz really goddammit
god damn I'm pissed off these people had
the most beautiful job in the world to
get paid to harass people and this is
what they do this is what they've come
up with girl Lamers disappointed
tambourine of shape I would love to do
this I'm god dammit you shouldn't be
playing that you're serious you
shouldn't be playing that game girls
girls don't play video games oh my god
this is embarrassing
good girls can they gotten someone that
knows what they're doing god damn it
good girls girls don't play games got
him oh yeah you're right I guess I'm not
playing a video game right now sorry
guys I didn't realize jeez what a MIDI
eh I'll be back in the kitchen right now
sorry about that guys
so dumb those words quickly catch this
shoppers attention it's like video games
for girls but not like that
you blew it you blew it
god dammit why does it bother me so much
yeah absolutely
why don't you just leave me alone I
don't even know you cuz you shouldn't be
playing that it's like this is a guy's
game girls can't play video games like
this
all due respect logically were alone ok
simp believe it stay out of this with
all due respect sim what I love to do
that man
and now another customer joins his cry
jeez you find something better to do
than her I'm not certainly can't play
games probably kick your ass with some
of these games well she's back up
I mean maybe you should mind your own
business - is it hey what does she say
she mind your own business she's a fat
kid I was surprising the wholesome
actually I will start things as these
were fake but I that one felt really I
don't tell them we're just playing -
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait hold
halt what is that a question mark and -
w's I guess what would you do is not a
gamer for like girl who made this am i
right
I'm joking why is it good to stand up
for a stranger like I'm an educator so
is what I do I see this kind of stuff
and I never want to see this happening
and yeah this is nuts oh nice
I get that reset that's a gamer
reference I understand that because I'm
a guy girls but girls probably don't
cringe we hit the reset button all
charged up they're all charged up
playing this game stop here look I got
you some movies stick to that stuff come
on hey look
got you legally blind on DVD go watch it
Hey look drop the spatula on the counter
what did you play with that Hey look got
you a sandwich maker why what did you
play with that god damn it this woman is
watching from across the store how about
she man hang but it's her daughter who
decides to stand up to our bullies
really do you think goddammit
step your game up literally is you know
these guys aren't gamers because they
can't trash talk first why are you
defending a stranger you don't know why
are you harassing a strange you guys are
ruining the video game culture like
seriously sorry what it's like a guy's
thing just hit him with a like oh yeah
oh you're a girl gamer bet your place to
do good anyone can be a gamer even if
it's like doing a Sudoku on your phone
but you don't know what the last boss of
until dawn is step it up please this
whole video is ruined as as the boys
leave the store she shows compassion for
our girl gamer thank you so much it is
surprisingly whole second issue I gotta
say I'm John quinones this is the show
what would you do teacher anything you
just stood and watched what are you
talking about she's the one that stepped
in guys feel like it's their domain like
my brother says that to me like no you
can't play this game I can what do you
say I keep playing it because I can do
whatever I want
listen I'm not gonna say girls can't be
gamers that's obviously just stupid and
immature but alright here we have a
society down full of society girls are
becoming gamers get that graph that's I
rest my case that's all I'm gonna say
about that don't want a minute make any
jokes against me trouble
but like the guys said that the
statistics are all there all day long
why are you even here you know they got
to do this all day long life just isn't
fair man video games are for guys like
other guys game it's a war game it's a
game if it's fun play
my god oh yeah it's a war game well you
have you been to war you little piece of
[ __ ] how about that it's a game
girls come play up day what wait Maryna
disappointment all right here we go my
son plays I like he plays with me okay
so she can play the damn game
my son plays online he plays with women
what does that sound somewhat
inappropriate he's slaying women left
and right he probably plays with women
cause they suck at it I'm kidding I'm
kidding
I'm joking like the whole just sir for
the record the whole game or girl we're
gonna get it's so stupid
they how is it even a thing I'm just
really killing the whole scenario not
the bad thing just so we're clear okay
these actors had the worst insults I've
ever heard girl lamer thank you so I'm
not the only one okay Gabe okay thank
you very much okay ma'am what is the
message you want to give her about these
things that men and women can do the
same thing we're equal damn right that's
deep man
I understand sexism ixus by the way okay
just so we're clear
it's an errors are so ridiculous I
cannot help but making fun of it we're
rolling
one last time girls don't play video
games like this why are you doing that
James Inglis there's a lot simpatico
look my tambourine is twinkling Oh
but will he press play on
will he press play on his opinion
disguise
check out after this commercial break
can't wait to see statistically there
are more female gamers players than
there are in guide gamers yeah playing
candy crush you dumb shut up hey what
would you just get me in there next time
please like they make games for girls
girls you're not your own being where
they can play real war games
what do you mean hit him with a dud
bottom that draws in a new food loss the
stool the crack addicts here we go she
shouldn't be playing this game you see
threatening to beat those kids up
outside nice look at the guy by the way
that would actually be me in this
scenario realistically I'm just kidding
well she's in a video games role-playing
video game ok guys guys go if she's
playing that's none of your business if
you don't know that girl find your games
and then thumps why are you defending
open your love and you say that girls
can't play games you're attacking
and now steve gonzales joins the team
[Music]
you just wanted to be quiet it's a wrap
for us as well a man how are you brother
how are you pregnant that's smooth nice
one why is it important to speak up yeah
this little boy do anything what is
meeting him wasn't brought up like that
this is your mom
tough lady well this is nice because
sorry one of my female and I have
daughters you're not a big person I had
to be harder what do you say don't have
a big heart yes I did threatened to beat
out those kids outside with a deadpan
toe but my heart is so big applause
tambourine applause that was beautiful
stand up cuz cuz I'm a simp sorry I'm
joking I'm sure there was this great
it's commendable that people step up do
you any former her of harassment I mean
that but I'm also making fun of it there
will be a day where you're the one
that's getting attacked and no one's
gonna stand up for you and in the end
when the players you know has won the
if gamers unite I don't even know what
would happen
imagine how society would be amazing
these guys are like 90s antagonist girl
gamer more like girl lamer hey why are
you defending us for you why you're
writing a strange John for real said hey
man how you doing brother while wearing
a full suit and tie nice 2016 girl
gamers 2019 we need gamer girl for
hydration see we already solve this
problem
next please can't wait to see what else
you have what would you do very nice if
you enjoyed this video go ahead and
subscribe I make videos almost every day
hit the tambourine become a member and
check out live streams get epic emojis
and icons and I don't know I'm working
on it there will be more stuff and more
live stream check it out thanks for
watching see you guys tomorrow
bye bye brofist
[Music]
[Applause]